you and I have been locked into the
World Series of Poker noticed a familiar
face on the ESPN broadcast former
Patriots great three-time Super Bowl
champ Richard Seymour made a deep run in
the field of over 8,500 amazing finally
got knocked out last night after the
coverage went off the air late finished
in 130 first place taking home just
under 60 grand and that's the greatest
finish of any professional athlete
fashiona ladder is a poker ever and then
the whole country was talking about yeah
he had this super fun we've a ton lap
bag and that he was wearing and the
whole broadcast just kept wondering what
was in the bag like Marsellus Wallace's
suitcase let's ask the man himself
enough to call in from Las Vegas Nevada
fresh off of an amazing run in the World
Series poker I have not spoken this man
in quite some time have you been Richard
Seymour you are calling in more heavy
pocketed than you were yesterday Richard
Seymour no it was it was definitely fun
you know I say I'll say that you know
you know I you know in spots like that
you just you know put it like this if
you enter a tournament with over 5,000
people and think you're gonna file on
table it you know it's a sucker bit you
know but you know you just go out you
have fun and then you know at the end of
the day you let your results be what
they are and and in this game all you
can do is make good decisions and you
know it's variance with the cars so you
know it's really a decision oriented
game how'd you get knocked down at one
hand knocked you out I didn't see it was
the coach went off there was late night
late at night right yeah yeah well
actually I probably had about ten big
blinds late in the night right and I
ended up seven King four on the button
so it just had to really get past two
people who or didn't have big stacks
themselves so actually it was a pretty
solid spot to kind of
get it in where Sudan were you suited
well actually I was off soon there but I
was so tight the rest I mean for about
30 hands I fold it like 30 hands in a
row bro
I thought out what I was I actually
would have got it through but it was
just very unfortunate because the small
blind ended up waking up with I could
Queens you know and so no comically he
called and then the big blind called as
well and he had eight four through a
third suited but it's funny so one
called and then the aces in the big
blind they ship it all in and so the
Queen's had to call as well so it was a
three-way all-in on the hand that I got
knocked out and anyway like I said I had
King four and it was a king high fly so
I bought the king the Queen and then the
ace was really pretty much drawn to like
two ounces one of the guys had already
folded in ace and then it came bang he
bent between on the tone you know but I
mean it is what it is I mean over just
some most spots that happen but um but a
Helen overrun Richard I mean that was a
a a heck of a run when did you first get
in a poker well I should I played a lot
growing up with my dad just kind of you
know cousins and that sort of thing and
then uh you know just even in the lead
you know we would have like Monday night
I will play with some of the guys while
we watch Monday Night Football we was
just kind of just fool around like not
even for like no money just bragging
rights you know when I play give me the
games I was playing in the game who big
John Henderson actually what my days out
in Oakland okay Big John Henderson
Quinton groves
you know and then actually remember that
year I think it was maybe 2012 we had a
lockout that was I think it was the
lockout 2011 yeah ma'am I was 21 2011 so
what happened I had the entire team come
down to Atlanta we trained down there
while we have the lockout so what I did
is I had some dealers and you know just
to kind of give you guys together
camaraderie we actually played uh like a
big team tournament then so it looks fun
you know it's just like I said it's a
fun hobby I'm competitive you know keep
your competitive juices going because if
I mean we still have that fire to keep
it going but you know so it's just a
great outlet well so you're saying when
you played Richard Richard Seymour here
on the Richardson show so you said
Richard when you played poker it was in
Oakland does that mean BB stands for
Bill Belichick not big blind in New
England we had a few games but you know
we played actually you know we would
always play like different games I
remember Ty Law he always liked to play
tongue and you know a bunch of different
other games so that's what we did with
those guys but like I said it was just
you know there's just something fun to
do and you know just great team
camaraderie all right so what's in the
bag Richard what wasn't that bag ever no
poker world you know what I just had
some ear bud close my ear buds in the
bag I had some some lip balm okay in the
bag buds Richard I gotta be honest with
you it's a big bag for lip balm and ear
buds that's a large sack for that it was
really more like a you know like the
Odell Beckham bit you know it was just
uh it was a piece that's what it was
okay so it's an accessory it was an
accessory oh I just love it Richard I
didn't go at the hoodie which would have
really been a Bella cheque move to play
poker with the hoodie didn't go with the
shade right you know what I mean it's
just all these poker players they sit
there where einer shades and with their
ear buds and and then the the hoodies
and everything like that
you can't mess with the National
Football League three times Super Bowl
champion where that's
you can't get off your game like that
you know what I mean but yeah you know
what I'll say this about a lot of the
guys that play poker you know a lot of
them have an online background and
they're so used to playing on the
computer ranks where they just make a
decision after decision so you know a
lot of them with them they just kind of
try to take the emotion out of it and
just try to make the right decision so
that's probably their only way and some
of them do well when they transition to
live and then you know because it's a
different game when you play online
versus playing live because the table
dynamic dynamics you get to feel other
people's energy whether they're strong a
week and you know I mean so it's a lot
that goes into it so but I definitely
get it you know it's a personal game
it's really a game about situations
people and just being able to just read
people will at the same time so yeah I
mean especially you know I guess you
learned never never fold pocket ends
when you flop top pair when you flop an
over pair Richard yeah under the gun
open so if you if you open under the gun
you have to really give their hands a
lot of credit and a tight range Jim and
I flat Tim's in the small blind and then
the big blind comes along with who had
the Casey shirt on B he comes along I
check I got the over P I feel really
good about my hand but he just opened
ships it right there he just jams it all
in and he didn't even care about the
under the gun raiser so like the under
the gun right there could easily have
Jack's plug yeah in that spot or you
know and he just opened ships it there
so you know I here's the deal obviously
I was ahead in that situation but you
know when you kind of sit back and
you're reflecting you look at it I would
really be guessing because the only way
you open ship it right there is like you
got two pair
or you don't hit bottom set or something
of that nature right you know like
pretty like this in a normal
circumstance I think in game theory it's
probably a call but when you take in the
factors of the situation and the
magnitude of where we're at you know
that close it's like I didn't think he
would just cut his stack you know I mean
cuz I would never just open ship it
right there but you know and that's why
I said it's player dependent now if the
other guy did it I probably would have
ended up calling but you know like I
said I mean we can all Monday Morning
Quarterback but you know I've been in
that situation you know I think you know
I was happy with land those tens down
even though all the head you'll just
know for the next time Richard next
World Series of Poker never get bet off
your hand by Andy Reid never never let
that happen
yep
never let Andy do that to you again with
his chiefs with his chips golf shirt how
much longer you think TV 12 plays
Richard what do you think before I let
you go oh really good question you know
what as long as he still has the drive
that he has and takes care of his body
the way that he does you know it's a
great system in terms of a lot of the
right people in the right places so it's
a well-oiled machine
you know III don't know I really think
it's up to him I think he's one of the
guys that said man you know what I can
set a new bar each and every year
continue to push the envelope and I
think he's one of the guys that you know
he can continue to push it so as long as
we keep winning and and keep doing that
I don't see any reason for him to stop
and if you're speaking attendee send
them our best okay Richard we have a
little bit actually I have I have comes
with it how's he doing and action yeah
actually we talked like three days ago
and he's he said he's recovering but I
was definitely scared for sure no I wish
him and his family the best hey Richard
Congrats on that run I was rooting the
I was rooting like heck for MI please do
not fold those pocket tens I was
screaming at the screen screaming at the
brain couldn't hear me from my couch in
Los Angeles Richard let's chat soon
Richard let's chat soon thanks again for
calling and enjoy time with your family
I saw those photographs of the Seymour
family by the pool while he was hanging
with his family by the break at big CSU
i-93 on twitter for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on Direct TV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app